Detox for babies from heavy metals or any bad chemicals in the you know what
so
Very very important
So I'm gonna I'm gonna answer that question
Okay, so if you know that your baby has exposed to the you know what and how would you help them detox that?
well, I would highly suggest you look at my seven phases of detox book
I think it's still available as a free download on our website
And we have a whole course on the seven phases of detox where I go in the detail
It's very common that people
Were exposed to something they know they were exposed to something or they what did some heavy metal test
And they know they have mercury or something like that that they jump to the last phase of detox, which I call phase 0
Which is chelation so they think okay?
Well, I got against out of my body
So I'm gonna start using a key later to pull it out of my body and I think there's a lot of danger in doing them
You have to start at the beginning you have to support the liver pathway and
But at the very beginning is just support how you get rid of it into the toilet
So that's the input so when you're trying to heal the digestive system you start at the
The beginning you make sure so I was good you make sure the person's chewing that you make sure that their hydro park acid is good
And their stomach and all the way down. Well, you're supporting detoxification. You started the in are they having a good bowel
It's are they buy you need stuff in the gut so they're not reabsorbing it and having it to go through the liver again
Is there a bowel is there bio flow good?
So they have a healthy gall bladder healthy bio flow and then you look at the liver phase one two and three in the liver
Supporting those pathways because if you were gonna just jump to Kielace and pull it out of the tissues and get it into the blood and
The liver is the rate of detoxification is slower than the liver you're not supporting phase one two three in the liver
It's just gonna circulate and go somewhere else and cause problems and it is going to circulate through the brain
And you can cross the blood brain barrier and if you're talking about a child
Less than three years old they really have a fairly non-existent blood brain barrier so it could easily get into the brain
And that's when you get into all sorts of
inflammation and causes of all sorts of problems
You do not want to jump to Kielace and you can't for sure
The adults who should leave don't too but definitely with a child on a tree out without use Kielace
So you're just gonna support natural detox pathways through
Phase six, which I call getting it out into the toilet. That's healthy bowel. We look space five by eating it in the gut
You could definitely use binders that are not absorbed phase four as making sure bowel flow is good
Phase one two three, which is all in the liver. You go through anything with phase zero with Kielace and the children
Lots more on that on our website if you look up
Seven phase of detox or or you could download my book the seven phases of detox or go to the course the seven phase of detox
Hopefully that will